yeah it doesn't matter where the king
goes to a5 as well it's just made in the
three basically yeah or through a7
yeah okay we'll have uh widgets
video feed there
yeah it's unfortunate it's a bit of a
combination of bad luck and uh
yeah i don't cannot say that the
preparation i wouldn't call it sloppy it
wasn't swapping it was all right
it's just a bit unfortunate yeah it was
very hard probably
uh but i know exactly what happened she
was prepared
i he was prepared just it's tough nobody
just
just yeah it happens just in chess you
cannot prepare to the end sometimes you
cannot always pray to the end you always
have some loose ends
and it was a small loose end which is
normal and he just relied on his uh over
the board play
which was okay but then he slipped one
when he slipped it was over
and dude did everything right so
exactly
this is very nice yeah and good that we
didn't got to spend some time right
after time control because
uh that was the time he needed to
get accept acceptance you know to accept
his defeat basically
because uh it was very painful it's very
painful to get it right right onto you
you need some time to recover
and i think in the last few minutes that
he was making these moves
he basically yeah he had some time to
get we'll come and get used to it
let's move on